there have been more godzilla versus god
teasers than there are fishes in the sea
as of late but are they revealing too
much of what is coming our way
there are two teams on this as well just
as there is team
kong and team godzilla so is there a
team not enough and a team too much
regarding the trailers tv spots and
teasers
here in this video we are going to
discuss two things
one is the argument of whether legendary
and warner bros
is showing the entire movie before it is
released as teaser clips
and the other topic is why is kong
trapped inside a barrier
in the last tv spot teaser we are going
to start with the revealing thing
and then jump into the gong topping
later on so let's get down to it
so we had the first teaser at ccxp last
year and then came the main trailer in
january
and then just like opening the
floodgates a river of diesels fell on
our lap
well we are showing whatever we get
since there are those who want to see it
and to those who don't want simply fight
the temptation
but that's a tough one isn't it so are
they showing too much of the movie
before it is coming
out in the cinemas in march a one cam
says so uh their argument has a solid
foundation as there are many scenes that
could have been hidden
from the spotlight for spoiling the
shock value later on
one was the fact that kong jumped and
sneaked attack godzilla from behind
ramming his head
into one of the skyscrapers but if we
don't show it someone else will
so team too much reveal have quite a few
valid points one of them is that
producers have revealed mecha godzilla
in the trailer
the first trailer that is but is it like
batman vs superman revealing doomsday
well that's far from it the
mechagodzilla clip was at the most two
seconds and that too if the internet
isn't filled with researchers and
sherlock holmes we would have missed it
mechagodzilla was barely visit from the
rubble and the human chaos
and even being seen later on in the
screens didn't really reveal the design
of the mecca
only a part of the statistics second
argument is that there have been
too much of the ocean battle scene
revealed to us
that i agree it doesn't mean that we
won't show it in the channel
but i agree however how the battle
started how it will land
how kong managed to hold his ground with
the big g in the ocean
etc and it just brings more questions
than answers which is quite a cheeky
move
of the makers of the movie getting us
itched up for
too watch the flick team not enough
says that godzilla vs kong yes had had
quite a number of teasers and tv spots
being released to the public
but if you closely examine every one of
them the entire duration of the unique
scenes is more or less equal to the
single
zack snyder's justice league trailer
they also have
a valid point as most of the scenes in
each teaser are
repeats of the previous ones with only a
couple of
new scenes stitched in between to
generate the hype
this team also had another good point as
more
teasers with a few unique scenes are
given the more attention the movie is
going to get
from all monster fans and new budding
ones
adam wingard the director already made a
statement that he won't repeat the
mistakes of batman vs superman
and we just have to have faith in that
but with our channel
and quite a few others doing their
section videos it is going to be a tough
one isn't it
isn't it adam so let's move on to kong
and the barrier scene
firstly as youtubers we watch other
people's content as well
it's like research and there is this
channel called wars2
that if i remember correctly said that
kong was not in scale
skyline that gong was not in skull
island anymore and that he had been
transported somewhere else that
he heard from a guy that has special
access to the storyline
and apparently it is true gong was seen
walking through the trees
and approaching jia and suddenly he is
seen uprooting one tree
fashioning it into a javelin and
throwing it at the sky which shockingly
broke
it actually broke he broke the sky but
the sky was just a projection that was
meant to keep gong calm and feeling that
he is back in skull island
so the question arises as to why corm is
being held captive
inside a truman show kind of world and
what the hell happened to skull island
so let's get down to it skull island may
be sleeping with the fishes in this
upcoming movie
it was too small to house a 400 foot
tall ape anyway
with not enough food resources to
sustain gom but still even in the end
credit scenes of kotm we were given the
news that skull island was getting
unstable and that new titans were being
drawn towards it
i guess the story of skull island would
see its end in either flashbacks
in the upcoming movie or the comics
kingdom kong
i suspect the hollow earth cavities and
camazotz the titan
would play an important role in the
destruction of gong's adopted home
yes adopted home as we are quite sure
his species
originated or made the hollow earth
their home in the past
so with the island gone we still have
gong and the question is
where is he now my best guess is that
kong was rescued or transported away
from the dying island
into another location that is very
remote and controlled by monarch
and maybe it is even underwater as the
next scene in a teaser shows
right after kong broke with a scene that
he throws a tree at the screen
anyway in my opinion that's a very
dangerous way to contain a titan
but it can also work as a failed save in
case the giant ape goes bad
monarch and its scientists have studied
and befriended the ape titan ever since
the organization came to know of his
existence in 1973
and with the 1995 expedition it is quite
possible that
they are using kong as one of the
primary assets to control godzilla
in case he goes on a rampage so kong
would have been transported away from
skull island
in a sedated state like in the scene
where we see him
sleeping on top of a ship he was sedated
as there is no freaking way that he
would be let into a wonder vision
westview hexagon-like zone
with a barrier out of his own free will
they are also playing out scenes of
daytime sunset along with the landscape
of his earth's while home
skull island to keep the giant ape calm
and contained in one place
but as we can see it is not fooling kong
his titan eyes
can see better maybe than us but how did
this happen
i blame the little girl gia so
that's about it we have covered two
topics in one go with this video
do let us know whether you are team com
or team godzilla in the comments section
and also tell us if you are team too
much information or team
not enough reveal and so with that we
come to the end of the video
hope you liked it and do subscribe if
you haven't since we are getting
to 200 000 subscribers before this video
is uploaded
and well i guess this is our 200k
special then
thanks to everyone a few monster fans
out there till the next one
take care fam
[Music]
and i promise to protect here
hbo max the exact same day